So far we've been talking a bit about
Grand Central Dispatch, or GCD but
without getting into too many details.
Time to put an end to that.
GCD is an open source framework
from Apple for both iOS and OS 10.
It's one of the crown jewels of
the Apple's programming stack.
For reasons that are beyond this course
dealing directly with threads in
inherently dangerous and complicated.
This is one of the reasons
why concurrent programming
has always been available only to gurus.
Not anymore.
GCG makes concurrent programming
approachable by mere mortals
by hiding threads, and
using queues of closures instead.
How on earth does this help?
Patience young padawan,
let's start with a queue.
A queue is like a line
at the super market,
each customer is a closure
waiting to reach the cashier.
The cashier is a thread that
picks a customer, or closure, and
allows it to run.
Once the closure finishes running,
it is removed from the queue, and
the next one in line runs.